Netflix says it doesn't let brands
pay for product placement.
So how do you explain this?
JJ: You guys see that?
That's the Malibu 24 MXZ, the
world's finest Wakesetter.
No. 1 in luxury, quality, and performance.
Narrator: Or this?
Antoni: Stores like this,
they're designed for the
Bobby Camps of the world, OK?
It's all organized in a very
logical, structured way.
Narrator: Or this?
Steve: It's finger-lickin' good.
Narrator: All of those scenes
are from Netflix originals,
and they all feature branded products
in a way that feels a
lot like advertising.
So if Netflix says these
aren't paid promotions,
how are all these brands winding up
in your favorite Netflix shows?
Clip: Refreshment you can trust.
A bottle of ice-cold Coca-Cola
when you're thirsty.
Lucas: Sweeter.
Bolder.
Better.
Narrator: Product
placement is nothing new,
and in the streaming era,
the practice can take a
lot of different forms.
Lenny: Because first, I have
to drink my Cherry Coke Zero.
Narrator: Some Netflix competitors,
like Hulu, have openly pursued
a variety of product-placement deals.
Amazon has ventured into
shoppable product
placements for Prime Video,
and Disney Plus is reportedly open
to securing product-placement deals
for its upcoming original shows.
So what about the world's
biggest streaming service?
Whenever Netflix has commented
on the brand presence
in its original series,
the company has said
that it generally doesn't
take cash from brands
in exchange for showing
their products on screen.
That's the old pay-to-play
model of product placement,
where brands simply buy screen time.
And in today's industry,
it's just one of many ways for brands
to land their products in a show or movie.
Most of Netflix's statements, though,
refer to only this narrow definition
of paid product placement
and don't really address
whether the company is working with brands
in other ways behind the
scenes of Netflix productions.
That may be because Netflix
wants to protect its ad-free image.
Dominic Artzrouni: I
think it's because Netflix
really wants to avoid that label of them
selling out in any way.
Narrator: This is Dominic Artzrouni,
and he's the founder of Concave,
a market-research firm
that tracks brands'
placements in entertainment.
Artzrouni: Product placement,
in most people's mind,
is highly associated
with paid advertising,
being invasive, selling out.
Narrator: Despite Netflix's efforts
to resist the product-placement label,
one 2018 study found
that Netflix originals
have more product placement
on average than non-Netflix originals.
And Netflix has a lot to gain
from showcasing brands in its content,
whether or not those brands
actually pay for the opportunity.
Take the wildly popular
Netflix original movie
2018's "To All the Boys
I've Loved Before."
Chris: We can't have these
contraband Subway cups
out in the open.
PS, that sub is tight, right?
Narrator: There's no
mention of Subway sandwiches
in the novel this movie's based on.
But Netflix's rom-com made
Subway into a defining feature
of Lara Jean's best friend, Chris,
who loves the chain's sandwiches so much
that she texts in Subway-branded emojis.
Subway is known to push
for a speaking role
for its products in TV shows.
Kamekona: But this
Subway sandwich? So ono.
Steve: How many of these did you order?
Kamekona: Five.
Kono: Five foot-longs?
Kamekona: It was a good deal.
Narrator: And Netflix
clearly granted it that
in "To All the Boys."
Business Insider reported that a third
of Chris' screen time involved Subway
in some way, and the brand was weaved
into the very plotline of the movie.
At one point, Chris is
craving Subway so badly
that she ditches their usual lunch
in the cafeteria,
leaving Lara Jean to eat with her crush.
Netflix got something in return for this
when the "To All the Boys"
sequel rolled around in 2020.
The movie again featured
aggressive Subway marketing
in its prop design and dialogue.
Lara Jean: Why are we in woodshop for our
Valentine Subway tradition?
Narrator: And Subway in turn
launched a special campaign
to promote the film
through its own marketing channels.
Given that millions of
people eat Subway every day,
that's some valuable
publicity for Netflix.
This type of deal is called
co-promotional marketing,
and it basically means
that the two companies trade promotions.
Netflix gave Subway cultural relevance
in "To All the Boys,"
and Subway helped Netflix
attract more subscribers
who want to watch this movie.
Clearly, it's a smart
business move for Netflix
to embed brands in its programming,
even in cases where the product placement
seems to happen organically,
like it did with Eggos
in "Stranger Things."
Eggo said it was as surprised
as anyone else by its waffles' big role
in the show's first season,
but after seeing an
unexpected boost in sales,
the brand decided to partner with Netflix
and play up its "Stranger Things" moment.
The two companies inked a deal
for a series of cross promotions,
including a joint Super Bowl ad spot
that used a throwback Eggo commercial
to tease the second season
of "Stranger Things."
Eggo, meanwhile, continued to appear
throughout seasons two
and three of the show,
a win-win for both companies.
Plus, after featuring a
brand in one of its shows,
Netflix has a pretext to
team up with that company
on all kinds of product tie-ins.
Judging from the long
line of product launches
around "Stranger Things,"
Netflix is fully leaning into
this kind of merchandising now.
And the show's been a perfect vehicle
for this strategy,
thanks to all the opportunities
for '80s nostalgia marketing.
Netflix has linked up with brands
to make "Stranger Things" waffle boxes,
several models of bikes,
and a whole slate of
clothing and sneaker lines.
Characters even promote
some of the product lines
in their costumes, with Dustin, Eleven,
and Jim Hopper wearing pieces
from Netflix's clothing collabs
in several pivotal
scenes from season three.
Calvin: That's a lot of
color for you, chief.
Hopper: Its cutting-edge stuff. All right?
Narrator: Iconic characters on the show
become inextricably linked
to certain products,
just like we saw with Chris and Subway
in "To All the Boys I've Loved Before."
In that way, Netflix seems to be following
the example of franchises like James Bond,
a case study of great,
character-based product placement.
Artzrouni: The Eggo waffles become like
a staple of Eleven, and
no one sees any of that
as forced product placement
because it comes intertwined
with the character.
The perfect example of this is James Bond.
Aston Martin has been with James Bond
since the beginning.
Narrator: In 2019,
Dominic's firm, Concave,
released a report finding
that over 100 brands
appeared in the third season
of "Stranger Things" in total,
giving those brands an estimated
$15 million in ad value
within just three days
after the season's release.
As of June 2020, Concave estimated
that number has gone up to $55 million.
And the biggest winner was Coca-Cola.
Concave found that the company's drinks,
vending machines, and signage
helped make it the most
visible brand in season three.
Its presence peaked in the finale,
when Lucas interrupts all the action
to give a big, long speech
on the merits of New Coke,
the flavor that launched
and flopped back in 1985.
Lucas: It's like Carpenter's "The Thing."
The original is the classic,
no question about it.
But the remake?
[slurps]
[sighs]
[smacks lips]
Sweeter.
Bolder.
Better.
Narrator: This moment felt
a lot like a commercial.
Clip: You mean you don't
drink Coca-Cola Classic?
Us kids like Coke.
It's light, smooth. It's the latest.
Narrator: And in a way, it was.
Right on time, Coca-Cola
brought back New Coke
as a special re-release with Netflix.
Scenes like this make the
brand presence on Netflix
all but impossible to ignore.
Yet, when Netflix saw Concave's report
on all the brands in season three,
Netflix's team reached out to Dominic
to push back on the use of one term.
Artzrouni: They hated the use
of the term "product placement."
Narrator: Netflix said that
it didn't accept payment
for any of the placements
in "Stranger Things."
Artzrouni: They claim
that product placement,
you should only call it that
when money is exchanging hands.
And that's a total misunderstanding
of product placement.
Narrator: It's true that
co-promotional deals,
like those with Coca-Cola or Eggo,
don't require an exchange of money
between Netflix and
the brands it features.
But as we saw in the Coke scene,
just because a brand
appearance wasn't paid for
doesn't mean it'll be
any lighter on the commercialism.
Artzrouni: You can argue
over who's doing the placing.
Is it the company, or is it the producer?
But at the end of the day,
we make no distinction,
because the viewer doesn't know.
It doesn't really matter
how the brand got there.
Narrator: Scripted brand cameos,
like all the Subway references
in "To All the Boys,"
might make you wonder:
How did the brand get there?
And how much of a say do
they get in the writing?
To answer this question,
we went to Branded
Entertainment Network, or BEN,
a company that specializes
in setting up product-placement deals
and that's gotten brands
into a bunch of Netflix originals.
Erin Schmidt: So, we take what the brand
is trying to accomplish,
and we go and talk to content creators.
In some cases, we get to read the script.
And if those content creators
are interested in that brand,
believe in what the brand
is trying to accomplish
within their piece of content,
we can continue that conversation.
The producer or the content creator
really guides the creative from there.
It's very easily not
going to work for a brand
if it just doesn't fit into
the storyline organically.
Narrator: So, if producers, not brands,
are running the show,
why do we still get moments like this?
Pope: 2020 mode with 24 MXZ.
World's finest Wakesetter.
No. 1 in quality, luxury, and performance.
Narrator: Well, the producers themselves
might be getting money or
free stuff from brands.
And since many of the
biggest Netflix originals
aren't actually produced at Netflix,
the streaming company can
keep some careful distance
from all of this, as it'll
be the production studio,
not Netflix itself,
interfacing with brands
and agencies like BEN.
In fact, a lot of the Netflix shows
that BEN has placed products in
have been produced outside Netflix,
like "Fuller House," where
they landed Jose Cuervo;
"Jessica Jones," where
they got Tincup Whiskey;
or "House of Cards," where they got
regular appearances for Dunkin' Donuts
and General Motors.
In titles like these that
are produced out of house,
Netflix will sometimes get a say
in whether brands make
their way into the script.
But if there are money
or contracts involved,
Netflix can pretty much stay out of it,
while quietly letting
their producers take fees
or free products and services from brands.
That happened with the
2018 movie "Like Father,"
another Netflix original
produced out of house.
Royal Caribbean gave the film crew
free use of one of its cruise liners.
In other words, a free filming location
for most of the scenes in the movie.
The producers modified the script
to include details specific
to the cruise liner
and the activities offered on board,
even adding a whole game-show scene
that wasn't in the script before.
This kind of assistance from brands
in return for product placement
can help producers save
big and stay under budget.
And it's good for Netflix too.
Schmidt: For every platform,
you want to empower your producers.
Allowing a producer to strike deals
or to do trade out with
expensive opportunities,
whether it be a location or an
auto or all of those things,
you're empowering that producer
to do that extra shoot,
to do that really cool chase scene
or whatever it might be
to move that piece of
content to the next level.
Narrator: On the one hand,
these types of
behind-the-scenes arrangements
can result in pretty heavy-handed
brand messaging on screen.
But on the flip side,
it can sometimes feel more intrusive
when shows avoid product
placement altogether.
Artzrouni: The thing I find
actually more unnerving
than product placement
is when you see shows
where they've removed the badges off cars,
or they've taped up the back of computers,
or, you know, if you have,
like, blank cans of soda.
That's not realistic.
Narrator: Netflix's use
of product placement
is a trade-off for viewers.
The kind of deep brand integration
you see in Netflix originals
is less disruptive than commercials,
and it might help Netflix stay ad-free
while continuing to churn
out high-quality content.
But when brands become
stars in their own right,
it sometimes blurs the line
between what's an ad and what isn't.